-So this show is based on
"Glorious Ladies of Wrestling,"
which was a real thing.
-Seth, it's
"Gorgeous Ladies of Wrestling."
-Gorgeous, I apologize.
I'm so ashamed of myself.
-You said the same thing
when my husband was here.
And I just want you to know.
-Oh, I got it wrong then too?
Oh, my God.
-That it's "gorgeous."
-Well, first of all,
I guess the difference
between the two of you
as a couple,
is that he didn't correct me.
[ Laughter ]
-They call -- They refer to him
as the polite one in the couple.
-So, I was so excited,
but well, here's the thing,
'cause I was aware --
that's even more embarrassing
for me,
because I was aware of "Gorgeous
Ladies of Wrestling."
I remember watching it.
-You watched it?
-Yeah, because I was at the age
where it was almost sexual,
but I couldn't quite figure out
why.
-Sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's still sort of
what our show is like.
-Yeah.
But were you -- Did you have
any familiarity with --
-None, no, none at all.
My agents called me to say
Jenji Kohan is producing a show
for Netflix.
It's about a women's wrestling
show from the '80s.
And I was kind of like,
"What an idea!"
And they were like, "No, it was
a real thing."
And I started googling it,
and the videos are crazy.
It's the most bizarre thing
because it wasn't
just wrestling.
It was like a real outlier from
what wrestling was at the '80s.
And it's like Hulk Hogan and the
Iron Sheik and stuff like that.
And then these are like, women
of all shapes and sizes.
Like on our show,
they were actresses and models
who got cast on this show
and learned how to wrestle.
They don't just wrestle
on the show.
They do sketches and they rap.
-Yeah.
-They -- They "rap."
-Yeah. There was a weird --
Post the Chicago Bears
Super Bowl Shuffle,
there was a weird, low bar
for rap.
-Sure, Blondie rapped in
"Rapture."
I feel like that's what their
style of rapping --
-Is it true that you had to rap
for the audition?
-Well, so, yes and no.
-Okay.
-They -- As part of the
audition, they included a vid--
They said, "You're going to come
in and do something like this,"
and included a video of the rap
and then had sample, I guess,
rap lyrics
and also told us
we could improvise.
And later, after we all
got on the show,
the women were all
telling their stories --
the other girls on the show --
about what they rapped
in their audition.
And I was like, "Oh, everyone
just rapped that?"
I'm so my character Ruth
on the show that I read it
and was like, "I'm not going to
rap that,
'cause it would be better as
a monologue. I will monologue.
I'm gonna monologue that,"
and went in and improvised.
But I still think that
the reason I got the job,
we improvised
in our wrestling character.
So I was being this, like,
Russian villainous character.
And I think I got the job
because of my improv about --
I basically was rhyming
Natasha and Boris.
-That's a good Russian
reference.
-With, you know,
"stomp on your clitoris."
-Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
It turns out, you know what, you
picked something up in Compton.
You picked something up
in Compton.
-It came around.
-And by the way,
I would be remiss to not show,
you got in
incredibly good shape.
-Oh, yeah.
-There you are, wrestling.
And, yeah, when Dave was here,
he was saying that --
Was this -- I mean,
have you ever had a part
where you had to get in shape
like this ever?
-No. I've been dying to have
a part like this.
And I've trained with my trainer
for a long time
and was really excited to do it,
but I would never imagine
that I would do anything
like wrestling.
So it was very cool to, like, be
getting stronger and doing,
like, extra strength training
and then also,
to be learning how to wrestle
and use our body in that way was
very empowering and cool.
-That's great.
And the show is really great.
And congratulations, and it's
always so nice to see you.
Thank you so much
for being Alison.
Alison Brie, everybody!